madeleine sébastien bons soins bonsoir
expert aurèle vous retrouver pour ce
panel on va commencer bon bain par un
set de conférence de presse de monsieur
fall ya tant de choses à dire notamment
sur ce qu'il a dit et sur le contexte
évidemment il sortait d'une longue
période de mutisme d'absence dans tout
cas d'événements publics
l'article un des plus populaires
aujourd'hui sur notre site web c'est
intitulé où était donc d'oxford
on reviendra sur les salves envoyé à
l'endroit de monsieur trudeau et du
gouvernement fédéral
écoutons me suis fondu trudeau et
apprendre en jase beaulieu l'un des
meilleurs fait l'objet
le premier ministre ford a souligné son
désir de voir plus de dépistage aux
aéroports à travers le pays
si des mesures que évidemment les
provinces peuvent instaurer eux-mêmes
on a vu par exemple dans la bulle
atlantique ou dans les territoires mais
en plus on a affaire de rendre
disponibles des millions de tests de
dépistage rapide que nous avons qui sont
pas en train d'être utilisées au maximum
à travers le pays pour faire par exemple
du dépistage de des gens qui arrivent à
l'aéroport c'est pas nouveau madeleine
qui me suit ford comme ça se tourner
vers ottawa pour jeter une partie du
blâme exigeait plus mais on a vu ce une
fin de non recevoir aujourd'hui c'est
pas nouveau que les provinces utilisent
cette stratégie leur de frapper sur la
tête d'ottawa lorsqu'elles sont en
difficulté mais je dirais que ça
manquait un peu de subtilité dans ce cas
aussi et c'est clairement d'oxford qui
est vulnérable donc c'est beaucoup plus
facile pour justin trudeau de l'ignorer
je regardais un sondage léger cette
semaine qui montre le taux d'approbation
des premiers ministres provinciaux dans
les mesures qu'ils ont pris pour les
mesures qu'ils ont prises pour combattre
la coved
le taux d'approbation de d'oxford il est
de 37 pour ça celui de françois legault
70 pour ça donc la semaine dernière
lorsque françois legault et d'autres
fois il avait cosigné une lettre à là
pour dire faudrait en faire plus pour
contrôler les variants aux frontières ce
avait eu du poids
cette fois ci j'ai l'impression que
quand dr refait un peu le même exercice
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour ottawa
de l'ignorer sébastien wyss a semblé aux
gars qui se fait montrer du doigt parce
que ça va mal puis qui disent pour moi
c'est pas moi c'est la faute de l'autre
en pointant un verre justin trudeau en
fait une guerre stratégie en politique
de s'enlever de la pression pour la
mettre sur quelqu'un d'autre ait trouvé
un coupable de la situation ailleurs qu
en se regardant devant le miroir
le fait est que monsieur ford comme mal
évalué la troisième vague pendant
plusieurs jours les spécialistes lui
disait
faut vous agissiez sur la troisième
banque vous prenez les mesures
sanitaires il a attendu sa monte monte
jusqu'à ce que ces soins intensifs
déborde puis soit plus capable d'en
prendre et c'est là qu'il a commencé à
agir donc s'il ya quelqu'un à blâmer en
ce moment c'est lui même mais c'est une
stratégie politique de renvoyer la balle
à quelqu'un d'autre la patate chaude à
quelqu'un d'autre
elysee fr d'aéroport la cc minimes
je comprends il peut y avoir des
transmissions recommande dans un avion
au canada puis qu'on a intérêt à toronto
mais c'est ça c'est le foot c'est pas ça
le coeur du problème en ce moment le
coeur du problème c'est la transmission
communautaire
ça c'est dans la cour de dom forgée
pendant le cours de justin trudeau là
dessus moi j'ai d'autres chiffres en la
semaine dernière le ministère des
transports nous disaient les tests à
l'arrivée là pour vérifier si les
personnes sont atteintes de la corée du
nord montre qu' à 1,4 pour cent des
voyageurs qui arrivent soit par voie
terrestre ou par voie aérienne 1,4 pour
cent des voyageurs qui sont atteints de
l'aco vide donc ce que veut dire la
santé publique d'une certaine façon
aujourd'hui c'est oui on n'aura jamais
une frontière complètement étanche mais
faudrait peut-être s'occuper du 98,6 %
des cas qui restent c'est là où il faut
mettre notre attention est aussi aussi
sur la vaccination
donc la course variant contre vaccin
faut s'en occuper aussi vaccinons
occupons nous de la transmission
communautaire
pour ce qui est des mesures à la
frontière il ya quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de mesures de couches la de
protection qui ont été ajoutés et quant
à ford il faudrait probablement ajouter
cette mesure de dhôtel aussi pour les
voyageurs en chine aujourd'hui
alimentaire trois jours supplémentaires
parce que ce sont seulement ceux qui
empruntent les voies aériennes qui sont
soumis à cette règle là mais c'est un
peu compliqué en lieux 117 postes
frontalière fois terrestre
donc ça fait pas mal ça fait pas mal de
deux mesures instaurées il ya pas d
hôtels partout le camp tour ces postes
frontaliers là c'est vrai dans leur
appel en vain qu'une un petit peu là ça
fait huit jours qu'on l'a pas entendu la
dernière fois il était
la gorge nouée en proie aux émotions
qu'ils laissaient donner l'impression
d'un premier ministre en perte de
contrôle
entre temps valait qu'augmente l'armée
débarque et la pad annonce aujourd'hui
on attaque ottawa un sébastien en termes
de communication une stratégie qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire c'est difficile parce
que quand tu es dans ce genre de
situation là il faut que tu rassure il
faut que tu rétablir le lien de
confiance lui pour faire ça il faut que
tu sois présent alors il dit que c'est
la santé publique qui lui dit de rester
en isolement
il faut le croire sur parole est ce qui
pourrait pas intervenir plus heureuses
je sais pas d'ailleurs ces deux ou
qu'ils n'interviennent aussi c'est chez
lui ou de ses chichis sa mère et il est
quand même capable d'intervenir sur la
place publique donc il devrait être plus
présent en termes de communication parce
qu'il a la démonstration à faire qu'il
était en contrôle pis c'est bien de
s'excuser mais les gens trouvent qu'ils
s'excusent pas sur les bonnes choses
il s'excuse d'avoir voulu me mettre des
mesures qui ont été rejetées par les
policiers par exemple vous fermez les
modules de jeux c'est une chose mais
s'excuse pas d'avoir agi en retard par
exemple sur le fond des choses il est
plutôt timide dans ses excuses et du
zoom ça existe alors évidemment on la
bri tout le monde l'a appris en cours la
pandémie alors ce serait possible
probablement d'être un peu plus présent
effectivement dans une période qui est
très très difficile pour lui en ce
moment traduit ça donne ça augmente
l'impression qu'il est hors contrôle
parce que six il se cache peut-être pas
là mais ça donne l'impression qu'il se
cache plus qu'il n'est pas capable de
gérer la situation
juste avant de passer au logement
logement et la crise ou non d'un
logement en ce moment je te petit mot
sur les déplacements interprovinciaux il
y en a encore une fois on en a discuté
la semaine dernière qui ont évoqué cette
idée c'est encore un peu dans l'air
aujourd'hui là dessus ça bouge pas
madeleine bien on a vu ce jeu 7 rue 12
est bon les provinces ont le pouvoir de
faire ça à lyon par exemple la bulle
atlantique existe parce que les
provinces atlantiques ont décidé de
faire des restrictions très très très
stricte la à leurs frontières pour
essayer de contrer la comptal
contamination et ça fonctionne et donc
ce que dit le gouvernement fédéral c'est
si vous voulez le faire
faites-le hier lors de l'appel des
premiers ministres c'est un appel hier
soir il y en a été question
mais on a l'impression que c'est quand
même assez compliqué là d'instaurer des
règles supplémentaires par exemple des
tests avant de prendre l'avion ou des
tests à l'arrivée et c'est un peu ce que
disent et justin trudeau d'ailleurs tout
à l'heure si vous voulez me détester
l'arrivée yeux des tests rapides qui
dorment sur les tablettes donc utiliser
les encore une fois c'est une façon de
pour justin trudeau de dire vous voulez
des solutions trouvées les dans votre
boîte à outils nous autres on a déjà
assez donné
crise du logement oui on parle beaucoup
de montréal dans ce dossier là mais ça
concerne plus que montréal et c'est un
peu le pet être aussi des actions
politiques même jusqu'à ottawa ça ça
reste à voir mais parlons-en de cette
crise où cette absence de crise c'est
selon écoutant des opinions aussi
contrastée là dessus et on y revient
début des années 2000 mais là bon real
si on regarde montréal à près de 5 % des
logements qui sont vacants et 10% au
total sont disponibles hors de vos rial
si différent avec des taux d'occupation
moins d'impôts de moins de 1% et on a vu
où cisco fait l'administration de
valérie cloud cdh annonce houleux
capable de demander au locataire de ne
pas informer le propriétaire qu'ils
allaient quitter leur logement avant
d'en trouver un autre on est en campagne
électorale on comprend sur des choses
peuvent arriver
bon si l'opinion de monsieur brouillette
l'autre ex-second voulais vous présenter
ce monsieur beaudry qui représente la
ville de montréal no qu'une opinion
complètement contraire diamétralement
opposées sébastien certains peuvent s'y
perdre là-dedans c'est pas juste une
question de termes crise ou pas crise et
c'est une semaine d'ici pour monsieur
legault qui pensez-vous tout ça moi le
premier je me perds bien honnêtement
j'écoute les hommes j'écoute les autres
j'entends la corpiq dire qu'à montréal
c'est 5% le taux d'inoccupation alors
que c'est à 3% qu'on est dans un espèce
d'équilibré
donc il ya plus de logements inoccupés
en ce moment à la corpiq que ce qui
pourrait y avoir pour marché équilibré
en même temps il y en a qui disent c'est
parce qu'il n'ya pas d'étudiants ce
moment qui occupent ces logements
il n'y a pas dit il n'ya pas ou presque
pas d'immigration donc la demande pour
les logements et moins forte ce qui
explique ce taux d'inoccupation est
relativement élevé à montréal puis de
l'autre côté j'ai des gens comme québec
solidaire on amer espérons qu'ils disent
regardez c'est difficile de trouver des
logements décents et abordables deux
critères ici des saints mais pas des
moisissures à tous les coins
daly tous les coins de la pièce et
abordable aussi pour des familles de
quatre cinq six qui ont des difficultés
à se loger donc c'était une grise
peut-être qu'on peut pas utiliser ce mot
là mais c'est certainement un problème
bien l'emblème des problèmes qui
rebondit dans la cour des gouvernements
alors ce qu'il faut des suppléments au
loyer par exemple est-ce qu'il faut
mieux réglementer les airbnb parce que
ça aussi ça le ciel que ça contamine le
marché il ya déjà que c'est qu'ils
s'achètent des logements qui sait des
rentabilités pilotes parce qu'il n'ya
pas de touristes qui les remettent sur
le marché en ce moment du locatif bref
c'est extrêmement complexe n'est pas une
crise mais a certainement un problème et
des logements ça se construit pas du
jour au lendemain on interpelle beaucoup
québec dans ce dossier madeleine est ce
que ta voix aussi peut jouer quelque
chose un rôle dans tout ça oui et ottawa
a voulu jouer un rôle en le ottawa
c'était complètement désengagée du
secteur du logement pendant une
vingtaine d'années quand justin trudeau
est arrivé il a voulu mettre une
stratégie en place pour le logement en
injectant 70 millions de dollars 70
milliards de dollars sur 10 ans
mabuse et a fallu du temps pour que les
provinces signent des ententes la la
pièce québec a été la dernière province
à le faire mais c'est fait donc il ya de
l'argent qui existe s'est vu du côté
d'ottawa comme une façon de régler
toutes sortes de problèmes pas seulement
des problèmes de logement mais mais des
preuves des problèmes de pauvreté
lorsqu'on a un logement c'est plus
facile après d'aller chercher un emploi
sa règle toute une série de problèmes
sociaux selon ottawa mais il reste
énormément de travail à faire il ya
environ 530 mille familles look sont
finalement dans une situation précaire
d'un côté logement selon les données que
je viens de consulter donc c'est énorme
comme problème et je veux pas utiliser
le mot crise parce que c'est un mot sur
lequel c'est pas tout le monde qui
s'entend mais c'est un problème et qui
n'est pas unique à montréal ou au québec
pensez à toronto pensez à vancouver où
ça fait encore plus longtemps qu'on en
parle
donc si toute la petite tempête
politique qu'ont eues cette semaine a eu
peut-être cet effet lol de remettre les
projecteurs sur ce problème là c'est sûr
complexes comme le dit ça va peut-être
se faufiler en campagne électorale comme
un thème d'importance au fédéral
évidemment quand elles auront lieu 7
cette campagne électorale sébastien ça
me rappelle aussi le débat entourant le
racisme systéme et que la reconnaissent
l'importance de la reconnaissance du
problème pour aller de l'avant
oui puis monsieur le goût d'y est des
bâtiments tic monsieur legault reconnaît
pas le racisme système et qui reconnaît
pas la crise du logement aussi odieux
que dans ce cas s'il sait c'est un
problème très concret là des familles
sont pas capables de se trouver des
logements
il peut être sans parler de crise il
faut à tout le moins reconnaître un
problème le gouvernement ici il s'était
engagé à mettre sur pied
quinze mille plat quinze mille unités de
logement abordable
il est en train d'en concrétiser il en a
concrétisé trois mois il lui en reste
3000 affaire on est loin du 15 mai on
est loin du compte très bien alors tour
à tour la semaine prochaine qu'est ce
que vous surveillez madeleine mais moi
j'attends toujours les recommandations
du comité de l'immunisation nationale
sur le vaccin johnson & johnson
on a reçu le vaccin qui est empreinte
des gelées en ce moment on voit comment
c'est la digne très bientôt
mais à qui le comité doit doit faire
part de ses recommandations - un vaccin
à dose unique on le rappelle sébastien
parlant de recommandations la commission
laurent sur la protection de la jeunesse
remis son rapport lundi c'est très
attendu ça aussi c'est un problème
complexe et on attend des solutions pour
mieux protéger les enfants du cul ça
sera au menu de votre journée lundi
prochain sébastien madeleine merci
beaucoup comme une fois pour votre
contribution panel bon week-end bonne
pâte pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit